all right what is up
hot breath the verse we are about to
launch
our live q a with jerry corley here
ladies and gentlemen so
without further ado welcome to hot
breath this is the show where you learn
comedy from the pros
i am your host comedian joel byers
and we have done almost 300 interviews
with comedians on this show
and our guest today our returning guest
is one of our most requested
sequels people loved his first interview
with us so much
it went from an hour of us talking about
his backstory into like a two-hour
comedy writing master class and this is
going to be
no different we're actually going to be
answering your questions so
if you're listening to this on the
podcast or watching on youtube
later all of this q a action happens
only in our facebook group so go into
the show description
and join this facebook group if you're
already a member of the facebook group
share it with a friend and without
further ado
it is time to welcome to the hot breath
of verse welcome back the one and only
jerry the joke dr corley everyone give
him some love
yeah thanks thanks man don't you love
this yeah you hear it
and yeah there's there's a sound effect
going on right now for you
applause sound effect ooh all right
so uh first off um just welcome back
you're like our most requested guest
back so um you really help a lot of
comics
what steve hofstetter was there right
yeah
oh yeah we've had all the hitters down
here like the million
view views on his the heckle thing he's
come up with a really cool concept
but you are like helping like hands-on
helping so many comics and i can't tell
you how many people here in hot breath
have just spoken praise about you and
your classes and just
you're providing a service for comedians
out there that
i mean we're we're trying to do as well
with our daily writing club and things
like that
but like you've you've really been able
to i
i just in knowing you the little bit we
have and then the ripple effect
you have that reverberates throughout
comedy is just
it's it's a very positive thing you're
doing so i really appreciate you coming
on here
to share it well thanks uh you know it's
uh i love comics comics we're like the
last
uh we're the rogues man we're the
cowboys and the cowgirls out there and
like we take uh that system when we want
to turn it on its head we don't want to
be in the system that's
i think what inspires everybody to be a
comic but it's like can be so
vulnerable out there right and it's like
and there was what i realized
was like no advice no really good advice
coming from like the mechanics of of
this
comedy is the most unexplored art form
you know and
so you have people that just basically
state what some other guys said and
what some other guy said before that and
everybody's like you can't
teach it you know you either got it or
you don't
i was like you know that's
that's not true yeah yeah there's form
to everything
just like i mean painting i mean there's
there's a blueprint that you can follow
to then make your own but there's
structure within the art form for sure
yeah well that with for sure so how do
you want to do this
should we just go into the questions or
do you want to yeah
i first had a selfish question uh and
then we're gonna jump into all the
questions here which we we're
we're at um looks like we're about we're
at 50 people right now jerry so this is
great
that's good yeah 50 people live
streaming so
um what i wanted to selfishly ask you um
is what we do here in this facebook
group
is a a daily writing club where we get a
random word
and then we take 10 minutes to write the
best joke possible
and i've been doing comedy 10 years
and there's people in here who've been
doing comedy
10 months or two months and they're just
killing me
on these jokes like
and sometimes i strike gold and other
times i'm like i get after 10 minutes
i'm like i'm embarrassed to post this
people are gonna call me a fraud but
that's all the process as well
of joke writing but it's a specific
skill set to be able to turn a random
word into a joke in 10 minutes so if you
could
for me and other people that may be
struggling in the right tent club could
you kind of take us through like a
process
of okay you get a random word like uh we
had a word that was mary
um like m-a-r-r-y and then we gotta
write a joke in ten minutes like do you
where how what's a good like checklist
for us to go through to like create a
joke off a word in 10 minutes
yeah and i noticed on i think it was on
one of your groups that somebody posted
this checklist
and it was like a copy and paste from my
book came from some other website
towards me and i was like i was going to
say hey bro um
you know you got it you if somebody
stole your joke you'd freak the [ __ ] out
oh i'm sorry yeah was no no no okay
so i just i didn't do anything right if
it was and it's there to help
but yeah so you got to cite the source
wow okay i didn't even know and i don't
know if the person really knew the
source i think they got out of somebody
else's like yeah i don't know
who who just basically copied and pasted
it hilarious but um i
go yup that's mine that's right there
because there were certain things in
my some of my descriptions that are
nowhere else like the
like coincidental or configurational or
there's certain things that people just
don't talk about
and so i go yeah well that's yeah all
right oh i'm embarrassed
i'm sorry buddy so not not don't worry
about us no i'm not calling you out on
that i'm just saying i just saw that
they said it as a checklist so here's
what i would do because that's kind of
these are the structures but it's that's
kind of the checklist but if you're not
familiar
if you haven't automatized i think i
just made that word up
automatize the structure meaning like
the way you drive right you don't have
to think about how you use your muscles
to get in the car and
start the car and put it in gear and
drive you just do it
which is why we kind of lose we kind of
miss our off-ramp when we're on the
phone talking to somebody and they're
giving us dates and times and all
somebody [ __ ] i just messed up
what happened how'd i do that because
your cognitive brain was involved in
something else you were actually driving
with your unconscious mind
so when you automatize the
the concepts right which comes with just
regular practice
you begin to sort of go through all the
possibilities so that one word marry
right away i see a double entendre
right it could be marry me it could be
mary you could be like uh the
a woman named mary um it's like uh you
know when i
my wife uh is large breasted when i
first uh
thought saw her she thought i was
psychic because i guessed her cup size
yeah she walked in the room and i was
like geez
right i was so taken aback i named them
marry
me so now mary becomes the the name of a
person
also mary as in i name them
marry me mary becomes the name you know
could be mary
like and get married so right away i see
that possibility
you know and um so i'll go through where
else can i fit
mary you know into that i mean right
you're talking about relationships
so you can go in i might do an analogy
i might you know getting married is like
you know something like that
or i might um so i'll go through analogy
cliche reformation
double entendre incongruity um
marry the name of somebody uh so i'll go
go through some basic forms and try to
find
as much as i could find on that then
i'll take facts dealing with marriage
you know
you know if you marry somebody at 50
chance you're gonna you know fifty
percent of all ma
fifty percent chance it's not going to
work i mean
if you think about that and then you say
um
um it's like 50 of all marriages end in
divorce the rest end in death so
what's the choice right so now you have
you can still get marry marrying the
joke
right so there's different ways like
there was um
first of all i love that right ten i
think it's amazing because constriction
enhances creativity
you know if you think back to you i
don't know if you you did this we you
know had haiku when we were in fifth and
sixth grade
right they gave us high q was uh haiku
is five seven five and we're like
what's it seven five seven always forget
yeah five seven five seven
five and when we were kids we were like
oh [ __ ] i'll never be able to write
anything on this
and we had to do it over the weekend and
then on monday
kids came back and read these poems and
you're like holy [ __ ] that's incredible
where did that come from so that
constriction right a lot of times most
comics
i find run into a problem
when they just feel like they have to be
funny and it's just as big a morph as
goo of
vague you know be funny at
what i don't have something specific but
if you give them something specific
now they have to tinker with jeff just
that
and so it just enhances the creativity
you find you approach it from different
angles right
so what's missing in a joke is you start
with one word
and then you go marry mary doesn't how
does that apply
is that you know mary is and get married
is it married as in
you know one of the techniques i use if
it a descriptor
like i think i do we did this on the on
the first podcast
one of i had this thing called 50 facts
right so i have people write 50 facts
about them and then bring them into
class
and you take those classes and you start
building their act through those 50
facts
uh so one of the guys wrote down on this
50 facts
lazy just one word wasn't even a
sentence right so it's like yeah i was
like uh
yeah evidently because you just wrote
one [ __ ] word
but but you know after ribbing them a
little bit the job is how do we step
this out though
lazy lazy you know top 10 reasons you
know you're lazy
so just that exercise the top 10 list we
know is the most famous
late night segment during david
letterman's tenure
but then you have before that it was
an exercise used in the joey bishop
writers rooms to write jokes
find punch lines top 10 list is a punch
line generator
you can generate a bunch of punch lines
on a concept
and now you have tags and toppers to
work with that right so top 10 reasons
you know you're lazy lazy at what
who what where why when and how right
you know so lazy what am i lazy at lazy
at
malays what would be really embarrassing
since we know embarrassment is a major
laughter trigger right and people
recognize that embarrassment
and also when you're embarrassed makes
the audience feel superior which is
another laughter trigger
so it's like um um if you get up there
and say i'm uh i'm a
sex that would be really embarrassed to
be embarrassing to be lazy at so
lazy love her and you could take it from
there i'm a lazy lover
uh so what are you know what do you
think of when you're
lazy lover if this is true what else is
true
what's my fa what's the you know what
would be your favorite sex position
if you were a lazy lover spooning how
can we accelerate that with exaggeration
you know
uh i'm a lazy lover some guys say you
know they're really great lovers i'm a
lazy lover
you know like my favorite position is a
nap
and now you have a crisp joke so with
like mary you go
kind of go through those steps and you
find you know where
the associations are you know and i
would just write sentences about
you know being married or getting
married would you marry me
you know uh what if uh mary is a term we
use a pejorative we use to put down
somebody playing golf
you know you know it's like if you if
you make a
a weak shot they're going come on mary
you know i don't know why
that became that pejorative but um what
calls you marry it's it's not a good
thing what i find is
when i when i'm able to create a joke in
that constriction
it's it's when i've when i ha when i
realize what the premise is
i almost have to like remind myself of
like
what am i even trying to say here first
off and then how can i make it funny
because a lot of times i'm brainstorming
for eight minutes
and then like i have like five ideas
here and nothing like
it's like honed in that's
just the key right so one word is an
idea it's just the subject or mary's not
even a subject it's mary
yeah it's it's like it's such a vague uh
application of the word so it's like
will you marry me
uh do people get uh how else do we use
that in a sentence
um um marry me would you marry me
uh he's going to marry her it's like
maybe and then oh there's a possible
premise like what would be the weird
relationship
you know this is uh in traditional
relationships
uh men marry women in you know southern
relationships
men marry their sister you know that now
you have a compare and contrast but now
you have a premise
somebody marrying somebody else how you
define that traditional marriage
you know um and in in in
in 2020 um uh people marry anything
right so that's how we've evolved over
the years you know who cares who you are
almost like a timeline of like what
marriage used to be and then what it is
now
as well yeah yeah it's not even marriage
the words marriage oh mary
stay true to the syntax exactly the word
and that's the challenge right
yeah man and also once you have a
sentence like sometimes you can take the
word and go
what if i pronounced it in a different
way marie uh marie
marie mm-hmm right so maybe you can go
french on it you know
yeah it was like um
there was a word i'll give you an
example of like how can we take this
further like take the word intricate
right
i was we were discussing the right ten
with uh on uh
in a group and i said uh it's a a really
cool
thing because you have to you have a
time frame right you have ten minutes
and you're given one word and so the
challenge is on it really forces you
to get creative now rather than
getting lazy with it and letting it go
right and then well
okay never mind i wasn't able to do
anything but it's like 10 minutes and
you sort of gamify it
and people put their stuff up on you
know on twitter
yeah and we started doing a uh it's
funny you said embarrassment
as well because we started doing a
monthly joke writing contest where
people get
uh a random emotional theme and then
they get seven days to create a new
90-second set based on that emotional
theme
so and then um there's three judges that
we'll judge and then we have a finale
that live streams into this group and
all that
so that's like another constriction
that's more like a motion driven which
is where a lot of the best material
comes from
right awesome well that's um yeah that
that was very helpful for me
and also the checklist that's so funny
because there is a tab in the facebook
group that says like uh it's like
writing resources and i think that
checklist is number one
so we'll go and tag you in it
that's very funny so yeah i mean if you
think about it
and in a general joke you know one
word's a little different than
say a sentence or a fact right because
the fact usually puts it into a premise
so if i have a fact or you know a
statement about me
i have five kids then i can go through
that
my checklist my first checklist would be
there's a three
uh three questions i asked the the line
would be
is there an assumption expectation or
image that i can shatter
that'd be number one number two would be
are there two dissimilar ideas
converging
right so uh i have five kids um
not really so but there is an assumption
there i have five kids
uh so you there's an expectation so i
have five kids
or you and there is an impossible
incongruity if i force it if i add one
later like i have five kids because i'm
only half mormon
um then then you have something like
that right so then you can go on from
there i have five kids from three
different moms
and they go up there's the judgment
right there did you hear that right you
could feel that and then you
comment on that right so you but so the
question number one is
uh is there an expectation an image or
an assumption that i can shatter
is there a double entendre play here
meaning is there a second meaning of the
word
uh or an alternate comedic meaning of
the word that i can play with
or is there are there two dissimilar
ideas converging
so once i go through those that say i
wasn't able to come up with anything
i'll say is there could i come up with a
cliche related to the
this this phrase this word um that i can
reform
you know um you know so if i looked up i
can just quickly look up cliches
now i have like three cliches and i can
try to reform those cliches
uh doing so a cliche reformation is when
you basically are stating a cliche and
everybody knows the ending
and you change the ending because
they're already thinking it's like it's
almost like dice man with
limericks right everybody knew the
ending they were already saying the
ending
right so you create that expectation the
brain already creates that ending you
flip that ending
whatever happens in vegas stays in vegas
whatever happens vegas you know so if
you give it context whatever happens
my sister just had a baby because
whatever happens in vegas evidently
comes out of your vagina
um so that was written by in a class by
one of my students
pauline yasuda and that joke still gets
big labs
but you know you these concepts you can
apply then you can do an
or an analogy you can drop in um then
you look for a paradox
um so these are things that people laugh
at that don't have punch lines
paradoxical humor
because it causes the brain to do a
little dance you know
that's a funny way to say it brain a
little dance
well yeah you have to write you you when
you do paradox it causes you to
because a paradox is when you take us
something that sounds like it
shouldn't be true but you find out that
it can be true
or when you have two things that can be
true but not true at the exact same
time like the word prick right so prick
and prick like george carlin's joke you
realize on tv you can say you pricked
your finger but you can't say your
finger to prick
so by definition prick and prick those
are two
things because that can be true but not
true at the exact same time
and when you run them so close together
it's pretty much the exact same moment
you know in the in the in the scheme of
things when you're performing and people
do that little damn oh [ __ ] you're right
i never thought about it that way
so that's the dance right they recognize
and go how come i never
it's right there in front of my face
that kind of thing
awesome so let's uh let's jump into
these uh
all these uh hop brethren and cistern in
here we got a lot of we're at 70 now
by the way so we are we are it's cool
and
the amazing thing it's before noon on
the west coast so
yeah comedians to jump in before noon on
anything no
they don't check in from up for funny
till about you know
one there's um in the right tin club not
to uh people are like all right get to
our questions
but in the right tin club there's comics
from uh like australia that tune in at
midnight
um all the way to people in the uk of
course there we have a lot of uh
right temperatures in canada so i mean
isn't that awesome
it's like global it's so fun it really
it's comics connecting around the world
i mean it's a beautiful thing i love it
it really is so okay we're getting to
your questions now kids
um and we'll try to we'll try to just
kind of run
through them a little bit you know um
because i also want to bring on
a special guest who is a big part of the
reason we're here
um teaser
[Music]
um this is the first one i'm seeing here
from lee hudson who is actually
a um one of our comedians out in the uk
he said how do you know when a bit
is done
um that's a good question because i've
had bits i thought were done that
evolved
later you know sometimes i'll do the you
know when you do the bit and sometimes
an audience member will say something
and because they have a whole different
you know life experience and different
point of view they
they might comment on it or tag it and
you're like oh [ __ ] i didn't
how come i didn't think of that [ __ ]
right and you and
and you you know i'll make a joke and
say thanks for thanks for that you know
i'm gonna
use that my hbo special you'd be in your
double wide going hey that's my joke
um which is weird because the guy's
british
but um the so the joke
it usually a joke resolves huh right you
can feel the resolution of a joke it's
almost like a major scale
like a song it's like do re mi fa
solatito
right so do remy fasolati good night
everyone no we need the dough
the audience will sit there and go right
so if somebody else sees something
another play that didn't get resolved in
that you know another opportunity wait
what about that
you didn't resolve that part of it and
they might say that out loud you go oh
thanks
never thought about that so usually you
can hear resolve well you make your
point because
every joke should have you're coming
from somewhere what are you trying to
say with that joke
once you say it joke's done
boom i love it nice nice
tight way to um say that uh the second
one
bob jorgensen he says oh
this is this is a good one um lise yours
was good as well
i'm just saying uh bob says with all of
your online content and classes
what is the number one rule that every
young comic must know
that it's an art i think the number one
rule is
um you got to remember it's supposed to
be fun it's comedy
so if you start beating yourself over
the head step back from it
and re you know refocus on the you're
supposed to have fun with this
take it seriously but have fun with it
and i think the i
i think probably the number one rule to
remember is picasso's rule
in art it's like um you got to know the
rules before you can break the rules
because it's an art form and you have to
remember that the audience is always the
final judge
ultimately uh and they're gonna tell you
because i might think man i got this
joke this is gonna wow
flatline what the [ __ ] you know happens
rarely
but then i'll go back and analyze and go
oh no wonder i left out this word
that's great know the rules before you
break them
michelle michelle van duzen
is there an easy way to change a joke
from making the audience
think to making them laugh
every joke is unique right so
it's hard to make a comment on that
specifically without the specific
joke but yes there's there are several
different ways to take that joke
in and what i like to do is when people
will hit me up on twitter or something
like that for
joke for some joke help and i'll take
that joke and sometimes i'll write that
joke
you know five to ten different ways and
show here if you want to pop try this if
you want this try this if you want them
really to ponder this
try this and then after they think about
it you can pop it over here
with a tag or a topper or sometimes you
say the joke
you get them thinking then you do an act
out to sort of clarify what you wanted
to say
and that they act out because now they
can see it in a situation they're like
oh [ __ ]
so when the waiter says this is much
funnier than if you just talk it in
third person
beautiful uh this is a
one from chris wright chris wright
actually just won
uh there was a this contest behind the
bits contest and he actually just won
that
um sweet he he asks he i think he was
hitting you up on twitter today as well
excited about this yeah uh look comedy
oh this
community is so beautiful so he's he
asks um
do you have any advice on how to go from
a one-liner comedian
to longer form bits while still keeping
the quick hard punches
yeah right great question so one you
know
if you take a look at brian kiley uh
brian kiley is
conan o'brien's head monologue writer he
he is
a he is a mechanical just like comedic
mechanics
you know down to the t right he
has found a way to sort of make the make
the flow
of the material sound like it's almost a
complete story so it rolls very nicely
even though they're individual jokes now
the key is i think you can take a story
or concept so i'll start like one and
two liners
sometimes and then it'll evolve into a
story a whole
story about um my relationships my
failed relationships and then
i but within the story all of the lines
every sentence gives you an opportunity
for a joke right so um
like when i first do a joke about uh
meeting my wife for the first time i do
a quick joke about that that could be
done
but then like if i say um my wife
uh it was my wife's birthday the other
day and for her birthday i got her a
gift certificate for his and her
massage and she said jerry this is a
wii gift not a me gift
so i returned it and got her a gift
certificate for dinner for one
and then you know then i can just talk
more about my wife you know my wife
my wife and i uh we've been married
about 15 years and
all of this now the steam is running
along and there could be individual
jokes weave together with tag stoppers
and act outs
and that's what makes it feel like it's
now a story or a bit
you'll notice that most of the best
comics you know
even sometimes the one two liners um
they'll get up there
and they'll do an act out and act out
just shows up as an organic piece of the
joke so we don't think about it as an
act out
and they'll get into an act out you
watch them on the tv set to get into
that act out within the first 30 seconds
and that makes the audience feel like
it's a whole story so there once they
see that act out once they imagine this
in the scenario you just set up with the
act out
you've got them compelled they're seeing
your sitcom
that you're shooting and showing them
right there in front of their face by
acting it out because they have that
suspension of disbelief sort of like we
have in theater
you know we know the guy's not at a
stream right now but he's splashing his
face with water that's not
not there but we buy it because it's a
it's a play and we suspend our disbelief
same thing happens in stand-up when you
do an act out all of a sudden the
audience is seeing the pictures
that you're creating and they're in your
story so it could be one joke
but done with an act out it just really
helps that joke evolve into a bit
yes yeah and that yeah that's great too
to
people to understand a lot of times
these longer bits were actually smaller
individual bits that evolved over time
and kind of you found themes to tie them
so they seem like it's one long story
but it was a bunch of individual jokes
that just kind of organically formed
into one yeah
and it's an application of the structure
right so if you say okay you say the
joke and you go okay well if this is
true what else is true
and then you could tap and so if this
happened what would that look like
there's the act out
right yeah so then you can say um
you know uh what's my what is what are
the you know who what where why when and
how
what's the contrasting perspective what
is that
well some people think this i think this
and now you're evolving it even more
so you're just taking it and using your
your your ideas and your techniques
definitely the maximum of the five w's
is one of your best assets who what
where why
when and how who who what who me who who
else is involved who will
else would this impact you know uh who
would hate this
who would really like this you know who
would think this was stupid
you know that girl right there oh that's
stupid you know she's you know this
so then how would you respond if she
insulted you or he insulted you
you know now you have a benign
retaliation possibility so
that who where why went out and how can
really take that story and evolve it
all right curtis walter
walter meyer great great kurt it's great
to see
all see a lot of new faces in here so
welcome everyone
to uh the hot breath verse we're so
happy to have you
um he says uh jerry would appreciate you
taking a few moments to speak about
tips you have for writing comedy for
variety acts
like a magician juggler a ventriloquist
etc
well those are yeah i've done lots of
that you know and um
you same same techniques are used right
so i had a ventriloquist in one of my
um workshops and we were doing
um an incongruity exercise through using
analogy sex is a lot like going to the
gym
and so he goes well how does that work
for me i'm a ventriloquist
my act is dialogue with my dummy and i
said tell me something more about your
dummy he said well my dummy
uh his name is uh i think it was monk
and danny danny was the dummy
uh danny is an old fart who's you know
blue
kind of dirty old man type of thing so
and now
now you have the angle right so if i
write a bunch of jokes that's a lot like
going to the gym
then i can take those jokes and weave it
into dialogue you know uh hey you know
um it's like uh so you have the dummy
and you're like hey uh good to see you
yeah well good to see you you know i've
been working out lately
you know oh you have you know it's like
yeah look at his forearm he goes oh wow
that's quite something he goes uh how
about the other forearm
well uh i haven't been working that one
out you know
it's like because sex is a lot like
going to the gym you know it's it's like
it's usually just me
right that kind of thing and now you
have the dialogue of the dummy
getting dirty and now each one of those
jokes you start weaving it into the
dialogue
you know because when in sitcom you'll
often have the executive producer come
in and say hey i need 10 jokes on
balding so we could because we have to
punch up this dialogue right here in cna
you know so and they just write a bunch
of jokes and they find a way to weave
them in
to the conversation so
um that's that's probably the best way
to do magician's the same thing you have
to have banter
i wrote for a couple of magicians uh
one didn't understand comedy and so i
had to step back from
uh that that magician um she actually
said to me after she she went up there
and [ __ ] up the jokes
and then after her show i watched her
show and school man she mangled each and
every one of those jokes because she
said it the way she wanted to say it
there is a structure to those jokes and
if you don't know what it is you
lose the joke so after the show she
comes up as people are
filing out she goes those jokes weren't
funny i said that's because you [ __ ]
them up and then she looked what
and it was like it reminds me of this
old vaudeville thing where
this producer's doing the show he's
rehearsing it and his his his girlfriend
goes i want to be in the show
and he goes okay honey what do you want
to do you see he goes i got something
for you i tell you what
what you do is i want you to sit at the
wait backstage and then uh when you get
your cue i want you to walk on with this
bucket of red paint
and you're going to go up to the man in
the hat and say would you would you like
your palm red and he says why certainly
and then you paint his palm red
she goes oh i could do that he goes
great so opening night comes out she's
waiting in the wings
she walks out right on cue right up to
the man in the hat and says would you
like me to read your palm
[Laughter]
she doesn't understand what the joke is
right how is she going to execute it so
i mean that
um that that's you know
what happens sometimes when you work
with people they can understand what's
what what's what mechanics are being
used what technique what structure
what what's the stimuli that's causing
them to laugh if you can't identify it
it's going to be hard to repeat that and
do it at will so
in writing dialogue the same things
happen but it gives you more opportunity
for
like with ventriloquist more opportunity
for benign retaliation somebody could
say something stupid you embarrass them
they make you look stupid
and you trade back and forth it's almost
like a conversation with you and your
wife
you and your significant other where you
each sort of put each other down
you know and i have dialogue with my
ex-wife i did it
did it you know i did a radio show at
klos
and um i didn't know this but when i
made a comment
she was i said when i found out she was
cheating on me with our accountant
true story um she uh
i i said uh i said i called and she
never answered the phone finally get her
on the phone the next day and she's like
uh
i said what is everything okay she goes
you didn't i go you didn't answer the
phone last night she goes well bob was
over and we were crunching numbers
that was her line i'm not making that
one up that was hers right and so i
so i said crunching yeah you're doing a
little division how many times is bob
going to you
and i didn't know this but the radio
guys had her patched in
all of a sudden i hear this voice well
at least it's just long division you
just did fractions
and i was like oh what a great show you
know
so now we have banter back and forth
right between
she and i and then i get her back and
she gets me back and the audience will
pivot back and forth
and love to watch that event so you
could do that with
ventriloquism right you can do that with
i wrote for
a mentalist who had to basically he has
his line he's setting up the
you know he's setting up the next you
know uh gag
and then in his setup you have those are
sentences that can
create double entendre opportunities
reverses
three-way buildups all kinds of
techniques that are still available
in in those situations
this one's actually this next one's
actually
a few people are saying yeah uh two
people are kind of asking the same thing
and then a lot of people are like yeah
uh i'm i'm curious about this as well um
so this is kind of like mitch navarro
and trent bab kind of asking the same
thing about
how to sound more conversational in
delivering material
that's a great that's a great question
because and one thing i emphasize with
people in my workshops is that comedy is
a conversation
right and so we forget that comedy is a
conversation
it's mostly one-sided but when you're
talking
you see your audience doing a lot of
this they acknowledge they heard or
processed the
the setup and that's where your timing
comes from is listening to them making
sure they're listening to you
they heard what you had to say they kind
of responded with a little oh yeah
okay yeah yeah i saw that and then you
punched the punch line
with it or whatever but that is a
conversation
one way to do it is to trick yourself
like um
johnny carson used to do this
um oh did you guys see this
um i read this in the paper in minnesota
it's a conversation now
ask questions you got you guys see this
um jay leno
hey um maybe uh did did you notice this
in the news today
that sort of thing right and so jimmy
fallon does the same thing
so you're actually forcing yourself oh
[ __ ] before i forget
i got to tell you guys these
these are little kind of things to make
sure you kind of trick your brain
and because we we've got this image ever
since we were little of what a
performance is
and so when we take that stage that's
still with us
rather than getting up there and going
you know holy [ __ ] i haven't seen you
guys in a while
you never met them in your life you know
they're going to laugh at that idea and
you know
but that's why in corporates i'll always
go sit down at the first table that's
you know downstage left and have have uh
the dinner with them or whatever
and then gas them their names and play a
little name game with them
and talk to them about you know their
time at the company so that way when i'm
up on stage
i can always go to my friends and call
them by name
and the audience thinks oh he knows
these people oh he's one of us
right away so they feel engaged with
you and that's a great question because
we talk about this with how people love
this community
comedy clubs that's why people come to
the shows they don't know it
because they love that to feel that
sense of community the moment you bring
them in and give them a purpose
that's part of the show magic that's
could make the difference of the entire
show uh um
taylor tomlinson does this thing which i
i i saw her
on one of her her last special i think
it was and it was brilliant
she comes in the audience is sharing in
her intro
and she's touched by the level of
enthusiasm from this audience and she
goes
and you could actually hear them ah they
pick it up
and she goes boy i can't wait till my ex
sees this that line
right there said you're on my side we're
gonna prove it to that [ __ ]
and they're like yeah we got you we got
your back we're gonna we're gonna prove
it to them too
so you've now working their superior
they feel that superiority we're gonna
get him
yeah you know and they're right on board
with you and she
just in that little line brought them
right into this community
it is a conversation right now yeah it's
interesting like
so you may have a one-liner that's very
rigid and structured but it's like
have a little runway into that one-liner
to make it a little more conversational
so instead of like
having a setup punch about your wife
it's just kind of like so i've been
married for three years and here's the
setup punch about my wife like almost
just a little
runway up to the punch line can make it
more conversational
and this is a great time to use crowd
work organically right i said you know
i've been married my wife about 15 years
how many people married you married you
married
yeah what's your name you know bill uh
okay bill how long you've been married
uh six years
uh one more and it's over right uh then
you have now you're building in jokes to
the conversation because seven you're
rich
and then you say but every name you have
and information you have from that
person how long you've been married oh
15 years
hey you and i we're on the same page
right miserable uh
so uh we say and i'll get a female's
perspective because it's always good to
have the female perspective because i'm
a man
i love to look at you know that's why i
bought cosmo i subscribed to cosmo when
it was in high school
because i wanted the other team's
playbook i wanted to hear other point
that other point of view that i'm not
privy to
so that opens so it's like when in the
in the classroom or
on stage when i when i include a female
i hear her perspective
and i'll ask them you know and now each
one of those gives me a joke opportunity
on top of that now i have
fodder to call back to right if you have
any kids yeah three kids so
i'll go through and somebody else has
you know how many kids you got three
three oh well we should talk to tim over
here he's got three kids you guys should
get together and [ __ ] you'll be the
brady bunch
right and then next thing you know we
get everybody's laughing because you're
making this [ __ ] up as you go
and uh being crass about it sometimes
just for
frivolous and now you can go into your
material
you know so i've been married 15 years
let me tell you now the one liner or one
and two liner
right and you build off of that but now
you have a conversation
sometimes the crowd work can be so
minimal one of my students she showed
she did a
she did a a set got a great response
and she did the the set again another
night and she goes it didn't go as well
i did the exact same set i said i bet
you you didn't do the exact same set
and she goes i bet you i did i said okay
what's the bet coffee
good all right so i said bring in the
videos do you have them she goes yeah
she brings them in
so the first she did virtually the same
set the same material
but in that first set that got the big
response she goes hi y'all that's how
she opens
and it's in l.a so people are little
whoa wait y'all oh that's quirky
giggle giggle right just a little giggle
and this one guy kind of made a snort or
something
and she goes i love the way you laugh
with this big smile and that made them
laugh more
community immediately community
oh my god i love the way you live i'm
taking you with me on the road
community where you just brought him
right in man
and then i said that's what got him you
had a conversation you were not in your
head reciting material
it doesn't take a lot just takes a
little bit of not afraid to look at
look at them in the eyes and engage with
them i love it
um here's one the off stage side
of comedy this is from greg brown who
says
tips on growing and gaining and training
the discipline to sit down
and work on the things i need to work on
off stage
so when you mean that's a little vague
like what part of it
the the admin part the business part the
promoting part or the writing part uh
yeah he doesn't specify
i would it sounds like it may be
specific to
writing but maybe you could also parlay
it into like the ad
like the the actual occupational side of
comedy which
isn't just writing jokes it's booking
shows it's working on your branding
it's like all these different things
like we romanticize
you know um like sitting down and i'm
gonna have a cup of coffee and write
my next great bit but and then we but
it's eight o'clock and we're like i'll
do it tomorrow
you know like how do how do we get in
that mindset of like i'm doing this or
else type deal
well first of all we have to you have to
start in like in micro gains and micro
wins right and there's a
book called atomic habits and it's about
making those little micro gains we all
think hey i'm going to write a 15
minutes in a day and that's not
necessarily realistic i've written a
whole new hour overnight a couple of
different times and performed it the
next night
still with my set list right there
because i'll tell you the story another
time i think may have mentioned it to
you
doing a fundraiser for my kids high
school club and uh they said dad
you're gonna do new material tomorrow
night right i go what you know
this is free right i'm not doing
anything they want to tell them what new
jokes
and i said i said close my door i'll
write a new act that was my challenge to
myself it was like you know joel buyer
saying
right right 45 right so
i had to i was up all night writing a
whole hour
now i had notes and things that were
scattered and i just put this new
material together
and knowing you know the concepts and
knowing how to like
you know how to trigger a lap what
structures need to be in there it was
easier but it was a challenge to me i
didn't know if i could do it or not and
all of a sudden i had it i go holy [ __ ]
and then i performed it and i asked my
son i knew it went
well based on the response but i asked
my son who is 17.
he's not going to lie to him i said
what'd you think he goes best one yet
and i go oh wow he said it was so fresh
and i go that's a neat i'm going to do
the same thing next year
so i did the same thing the year that
next year but
sitting down and writing it starts with
when i first started man one joke was a
[ __ ] challenge man why do i even
start so i would then take headlines and
i'd use that process
of you know asking the questions of each
line
and then once i wrote that first joke i
was like wow now robert orban
who was like one of the guys i was
studying as a joke writer way back in
the day
he said he wrote 25 jokes in the morning
just to warm up
and i'm like oh [ __ ] i can't even write
three i suck
right and then i just kept pushing now
what helped for me was i hired
coaches right and my dad said you know
if you're going to write for late night
tv i said that's really
an interest of mine you said you got to
get a coach you got to get somebody
knows what they're doing
i go dad there's no coaches in comedy
come on doesn't work that way
and then my mom gave me a writer's
digest and the back was an advertisement
and it was from gene parrott
to uh and to join his correspondence
course and then i wrote him
and he says and i said can i coach with
you one on one and he was like where do
you live i said chatsworth he goes i
live in studio city you're 20 minutes
away
we can do this and so we started meeting
once a week
and then um he had a colleague of his
that
he when he couldn't make it he would you
know this guy bob mills
would uh talk to me and they gave me
tips encouragement so i tried jokes and
they'd give me pointers
so it's practice is one thing practice
with expert feedback is a totally
different thing
because of those guys in 18 months of
coaching that's what got me
to the tonight show so was that coaching
that
little hey you know it's like make this
adjustment right here you know you can
try this
and then i evolved from that being on
stage because none of those guys were
performing on stage
i was taking some of the hypotheses that
they were coming up with
trying them on stage and tweaking those
based on live live performance
so so what i would do is i would sit
down
and i would map out my day and my day is
very important
an agent of mine said if you're not
doing 10 phone calls for your business
for your career
you're not doing your job and i said oh
thanks
for that that gave me a goal 10 calls
this would be 10 emails 10 reaching out
10 connecting with
somebody on linkedin or trying to do
something can i get an appointment to go
and meet a new manager
right i might not be ready but i show
them my video and they'll give me the
feedback
and they'll say we're looking looking
for this and then you try to tweak it to
that and now you show them they go yeah
and you they you prove that you do the
work you know they're gonna take it
people are
looking for good talent right they need
to know that you're
out there doing the work don't take no
as a no so i'd map out my day
and this between this hour and this hour
i am doing
um my avails i am sending out emails i'm
making phone calls
and i'm mailing packages i'm doing [ __ ]
that no other comics doing
because what is every comic doing
they're sending out a link
or somewhere even worse hey uh google me
or look me up on youtube you're gonna
have a comic or are you gonna have a
booker
uh do the extra work to find your video
it should be right there
and then um so i'll send them something
you know i'll find a way to send them
something
and i'll send them lunch you know send
them lunch and a
and a qr code you know while you're
eating your lunch uh you know take a bit
use this qr code to look at my six
minutes interesting
in a neat little card and i'll call the
club call the club call the club finally
say well what is what does tommy like to
eat
for lunch well he likes his chinese
place right down right next door
and it's like what's his favorite and
gives me and then i'll call that place
and
send them with the card to send over
with this with the food
buy them lunch and it's uh from jerry
corley here use this to check out my
video
and they're like oh [ __ ] nobody does
that so that's
a certain portion of the day that's
dedicated just to that then our next
another portion of the day is dedicated
to my
my joke writing uh and then another part
of the day is
dedicated to my social media or whatever
with and it's hard man it's hard to do
all of that yeah
but if you think of yourself like an
enterprise all of those things are
different departments in your enterprise
and your day job is your revenue part of
your
business you know that's bringing in the
revenue to help you to put
food on the table and survive and keep
your business
moving along as it starts as you're
working that startup
you know but if you don't divide that
time and put it
in your datebook or put it on your on
your phone
as a time reserved for this as an
appointment for yourself
then you're not going to get to it yeah
and at the end of the day and this may
have been something ted alexandro
said on here but it's well one thing he
said was that you'll never regret
working
harder which i enjoyed but it is also
like
you're willing to structure your day
around a boss you may not like so why
wouldn't you
also show the same discipline to
yourself and to your comedy career
and structure your day around a career
you actually want to pursue
so at the end of the day a lot of people
want the magic bullet
but it is like hey schedule it
and commit to it and the more you do
that the easier that habit becomes and
the more
just reflexive it becomes that's why uh
the right ten clubs started in
quarantine we've been doing it over six
months because i was like
oh man i'm about to we're i don't know
when live shows are coming back
i need motivation to write i was like
well let me just start writing online
and see what happens and now it's grown
into
this like international online writing
community
but it all started with me like i need
some sort of accountability
so every day at 10 a.m i'm just gonna
write and now it's grown into this
community
but it all does start i think with
scheduling it
and then like you said having uh having
coaches or um that's kind of like a
built-in accountability system so it's
not all on you hold yourself accountable
to someone else
and i like the micro gains as well of
a lot of the times we try to write that
next great hour
in one sitting but sometimes it's like
hey i
i wrote a setup punch no it's not funny
no it really doesn't make sense
no i'll never say it but i sat down and
i exercised the muscle of writing
and that's the victory today check it
off i scheduled it i did it and the more
you do that the easier it'll become
yep exactly jerry seinfeld used to have
a calendar and it had you know he put a
red x and every day that he wrote and
the idea was don't break the chain don't
break the chain don't break the chain
so if you keep that habit up it's so
much easier to keep it
awesome all right so um
there are i know a few people a few
people have a few questions but i do
um i want to bring in our special guest
because the reason we're here
what i've started doing here at uh the
hot breath verse we call it
is if someone reaches out
to a comic if they book that comic then
i want to bring them on the show and
actually connect with that comic
directly and we've done it a few times
and i'm so thrilled to um do it with
really one of our
right ten club oh geez he uh he's a
teacher and he'll like sneak
in the right tin club while at work it's
hilarious but
um let's uh let's welcome to the show
the one and only bo johnson everyone
let's uh
let's show bo some love here everyone
let's give them some love
i'm gonna do a clapping sound effect
there you go
bo hey bo how you doing buddy
awesome how are you i'm doing great man
uh first off thanks for
connecting with jerry making this happen
uh the timing is perfect
so um thanks for all you do here in the
hot breath
verse and did you did you have any
questions for jerry or do you just want
to
get a little face time well definitely
questions um yeah you know i know we
have several people
in the hot breath that are interested in
getting into um
late night and so i know that's been
been one of the big questions we do see
a lot is
how do i start that process of getting
into late night writing
well first of all i think it's a you
know it's a daily thing right you find
you get on you look at your news app or
you get on get online
find your regular place you go for that
news source
and um you start to look at the
the headlines that kind of resonate with
you that that trigger and emotion
and eventually you'll be able to
identify some that you know will truly
trigger an emotion with your audience
like
you know i mentioned like if there's
anything about tom brady
um people love him or hate him and
there's going to be you know if there's
a story about tom brady people will pay
attention
and they'll now if you can then write a
joke about it it's going to
they'll be more involved than if it's
just the general
you know idea now it's one thing to just
have
relatability or recognizable or
something that's familiar
it's another thing that have people that
are either that are fans because when
they're fans
that's a big that's a big emotion which
is why trump is
so often used in late night you know we
write what's in the news
and trump by design makes sure he's in
the news every single day so who do you
think we're going to be writing about
so when people get upset about you
disrespecting the president
really dude i was i was on staff at leno
when they were making fun of uh
bill clinton for like 12 years after
monica lewinsky
uh it happened and it was still going on
so and i wrote some of those jokes so
get over it you know but i think the
thing is like
you got to start writing the goal most
of these writers write 25 to 40 jokes a
day
um so that you know what you're that
threshold that's expected of you
um then once you're once you're good at
it
there are ways to reach out that are
kind of built around the system
uh one of the things i would suggest to
people is
um do a youtube you know build up your
fans
my friend charlie my student charlie
behrens he has the mana to walk minute
and it's a niche character he's from
like this wisconsinite that don't you
know
and he's got the he wears like a camo
windbreaker and he's up
in a hat and he just does he does local
and national news
but only for about a minute and 35
seconds there's this little quick
thing he does some relatability to
wisconsin some local stuff
some national stuff quick jokes nothing
really too offensive
just you know always keeping his
eyebrows up and you know keeping it
absurd as opposed to negative instead of
going like this and getting
you know judging people's ideals so he
went from when i first found out he was
doing this
a it was last september october he had
77
000 subscribers at youtube and he was
selling out rooms
of fans doing one night he sold out
flappers main room
four o'clock in the afternoon on a
saturday who sells out a comedy club
four o'clock in the afternoon on a
saturday
right i was blown away i went to go see
it and then talk to him afterwards he
goes i'm just doing what you told me to
do
you told you when i asked in class how
do we break through this i said get a
niche character
you know develop a social media appeal
keep it short and tight
and then people will start to identify
with the character
and but he even man he's got them
reminiscing about where they used to
live
all that stuff they want to come back
now he's at i think 150
000 subscribers that's great on youtube
in less than
a year and um now he's you know he's
doing some other
things he's selling product he's selling
merch and
people love this character and his jokes
aren't that great
but the character is great and so we
love the jokes through the character the
jokes themselves mechanically you go
but the character sells the jokes so
that's like a sitcom in a way i have a
feeling this guy's gonna have either a
special or a sitcom in the next two
years
you know because that character's so
like likable
um but if you're doing something you're
putting out really quality material
every chance you get two or three times
a week
eventually somebody's gonna take notice
if your numbers start and you stay
consistent your numbers really start to
go up there
and you know if he hits half a million
if he hits a million
um he's gonna get a deal right so
that's one way that's outside the system
the other way
is when you're getting good and you see
you're writing 20
to 40 jokes consistently usually 25 to
40
um and you're putting out good content
you're running by your friends your
friends are going
hey man that's some really good stuff i
would listen to you
but you got to make sure you're getting
good advice um
then one of the things to do is to
follow the credit crawl
on what shows you're targeting and maybe
think about targeting two or three
and follow the credit call in the credit
card you're going to see
a title called supervising writer and
supervising writer is usually the head
writer
then you'll find that you you can look
at the bottom of the credit crawl and
say oh it's filmed over at cbs
or you know most of them are in new york
called the production office of that
show
and even if you just call the main lot
and you say
i'm looking for a conan i'm looking for
kimmel
or i'm looking forward to both these are
in la um i'm looking for
stephen colbert's show um then they say
we'll put you right through or else you
get this phone call production
then you just say the name of the person
who is
william dadfree hey bill dadfie
yes speaking hi jerry corley you never
heard of me
but you know i'm uh a writer
and i wanna could you take a moment and
share with me what specifically you look
for in a submission package
and then they're like if i'm a writer
and somebody called me
i go dude's doing what he's supposed to
be doing that's cool
kudos to him and i would take a moment
but if i was in a super hurry i'd say
hey can we do this another time i'm
slammed
i and i'd call back 30 times until he
picked up the phone again
you know and but is it's polite
persistence
polite persistence polite persistence
never take no as a no never take a hang
up as anything but
hey we're busy um if you stay persistent
you will get better and you'll break
break down that door there were eight
people that
quit there were eight jobs that could
become available in late night tv
just this during this last six months
that's
a huge number people deciding you know
what they're they're
now good time to retire or retire early
or
move on or do whatever whatever their
motivation
anytime something happens like that
that's opportunity right so
if you stay persistent and you keep
writing you keep writing as if you have
a job
your job is to get the job your job is
to have us have material ready for the
pitch
that's not even happening right now but
it will it'll be that opportunity
where uh somebody says hey send me a
packet or i would just send in packets
randomly and find some creative way of
doing it
you know um so it takes no this case you
know like for example
if i was bugging the head writer and i
already got a packet written
all i have to do now is tweak it to what
spec specifics
they gave you they gave me and
and it's just a little tweak and they
say yeah well i look for this this this
and this
and if it was in la i would get on my
word
uh and tweak it then print it out put it
in an envelope
call a messenger have the messenger
delivered right over to the production
office
that day like three hours later he gets
a packet from me he'll go holy [ __ ] who
is this dude
you know that's impressive so that's
another way now not everybody has that
opportunity
you can overnight it or something do
something different but you got to stay
consistent that's um it's a challenging
level to be you're working with a lot of
guys who are good at this or a lot of
guys and gals who are good at this
but they're always looking for new
talent
if i'm a head writer my job is to make
sure my host has the best material make
sure i've got the staff with the most
creative writers
uh that come up with good content if
they're not producing i give them a
little kick in the butt
if they don't work if they are still not
producing like i need them to produce
then they're probably going to be let go
and then so i'm always looking for
somebody good if you're consistently
sending a material this guy's got great
shitty right so yeah prolifically
uh and he's always got some stuff coming
in
that opportunity may uh arise and
you also find different ways to get
their attention
one of my students she went goes to the
seminars at the
television academy of arts and sciences
they have these seminars and often have
like conan will speak or colbert will
speak
and she'll go to them and uh she's in a
wheelchair she just rolls right up there
and says hi you know and introduces
herself gets a picture with them tries
to give him a tape
and talks to them about how you get on
the show as a comedian
she's breaking the rules man and meeting
people and handing them packets
so it's just a matter of find out where
they're making personal appearances
you know i had my uh my my friend lou
mojellowitz
uh from vegas a comedian he um
was in one of my workshops he goes how
do i do that i go you got leno
shows right up here at the at caesars
every friday night
so why don't you go down there have a
packet ready with a bunch of monologue
jokes
and uh go to the state find out where
the stage stage door is
go to the stage manager and see if he
can deliver it to leno
and um waiting out in front of the stage
door was bobby slayton
he sees this packet this comedian
looking dude walking up with a pack he
goes
you got a packet of jokes for jay don't
you he goes yeah he goes i'm on his
plane with him i'll hand him to him
personally
and he did and two months later lou gets
a call from leno
you know and then um uh he he said what
do you want do you want to be a comic do
you want to be a writer he goes
i want to be a comic well i can't use
you then i said dude what you
you want the job right you said i want
to be like you jay i want to do both
um you know and then you say to him i'm
not getting off the
if you're on the phone with the decision
maker you say you know my job right now
is not to get off this phone until i
have a job writing for you right
you know that's that's the purpose right
now and so they'll laugh at that because
nobody asks
for the job yeah they expect somebody to
just hand it to them
polite persistence yeah so
when you're in this writing room with
other late night writers is there are
there
certain news sources you go to to look
for stories are they
all on up for grabs what what is the
process you would normally go through
well i have my typical process is to
i used to go like yahoo was the thing it
always had
nicely written headlines and now it's
all changed because
you'll see cnn and uh every one of the
major outlets except for reuters and ap
every one of those guys are writing
click bait headlines
because they're trying to heighten your
curiosity get you to click the story
and so when you get into that story
you've got to look at the first couple
of paragraphs to find the actual
headline to find the joke
what the what the story is about and so
that's where i think comedians make a
big mistake
they sort of just reprint the headline
and that's not how somebody talks a host
would never
say something like you say a headline
like that they they basically hey did
you guys hear about this like it's a
conversation
and now you have the setup so i would my
sources are mostly um
sometimes cnn new york times uh i go to
like
aggregate sources uh
refdesk.com will often have
so many different sources on there
news.google.com
also has so many different sources if i
find a story i like
i can click uh you know you know a
deeper search it says
review all it'll show all these news
sources that are writing the same story
and some of them will actually write the
headline that you need
and you go oh that's exactly what i'm
looking for right there it's already
written
um because it's coming from a different
source remember
most of these people are copywriters so
they're taking the main story coming
from ap
wire or reuters and they're rewriting it
for their
you know their rag their their online
source
uh also i would go to like local
news channels like you know here we have
ktla morning news or ktla
channel 5 news i'd click them because
now you're listening to people say it
the way it's spoken
rather than the way it's written and a
lot of times listening to cnn in the
morning or something when i first
started
i'd listen to somebody say the line and
sometimes the joke is right there
like oahu hawaii today lost power to the
entire island
and this already that's already a setup
you know
um and it was like and then what she did
she almost wrote the joke she goes
traffic lights were out court buildings
were shut down and about a hundred
thousand kids
stayed home from school today now i know
once she says
those two three ideas i can eliminate
one and just do a three-way build
up she already wrote the joke for me you
know oahu who i lost power to the entire
island traffic lights were out core
buildings were shut down
and a vacationing don king was seen with
flat hair
so because there's no electricity now
you have a joke that's suitable for
the tonight show it's not great for
stand up
i wouldn't do it in stand-up club i'd do
it for the tonight show because that's a
different
little late show audiences are a little
different you know so that's kind of how
i would do it and i you know i have i
still have a process i still sit down
and write
uh jokes every day you know on current
events
speaking of writing jokes every day i
know of whoops sorry a few of our
newer comics who just got into this
struggle with that idea of
what do i write about my life nothing
about my life is funny but so what do i
write about
and earlier earlier you referenced to um
one of your students you gave him 50
questions
not going through all 50 of them but
what are like maybe like five ideas that
they could
questions they could answer to
themselves ask themselves if that
could get them started with writing yeah
that's a great one it's like um
um what what is your ill relationship
status
because it's primal right those are the
things that we deal with we deal with
things that are primal sex procreation
survival
money uh struggle with money shelter
food
um i like to talk about things that that
uh actually
prompt the brain to produce serotonin
like uh
the food network has figured it out
right they just show you this food
and they're like and plus they gamified
it and added the competition with a
countdown clock what the
what the [ __ ] else can they do to create
drama right and we're like and we see
the food in our mouth waters and
our brains are releasing this serotonin
and we're like oh man i gotta
let's watch the food network again you
know i eat i cook so much more now since
watching that
those shows but what what you can do
is like you you know that's another
subject we can talk about that's the
food network it's an experience i have
and people can relate to that because
it's all of that's relatable a lot of
people go to porn because there's shock
value
there i would i would take what
everybody else is doing and go the other
direction
you know it's okay to drop something in
one time as a reference you know
uh it's like oh somebody's been watching
a lot of porn if it's in the moment
that's fine but don't i would go you
know you see everyone
smoking weed you know you can just
pretty much rattle off what everybody's
talking about
go the other direction uh and find the
nuances
in life and those little things and it's
like when joel
uh gives you that one word is maybe
something you
would have never written on before but
now you're forced
to so it's like what are people talking
about let me go
to some of this minutia in life that
is people see it but they don't talk
about it yeah like you ever watched
somebody wait for the bus
and you sort of step out now where's the
incongruity where's the
paradox where's the irony in that them
waiting for the bus they wait on the bus
they're on the curb that's seven inches
high
they look for a bus that's 16 feet tall
i know i've measured
uh and they're waiting for the bus they
don't see the ball so they step down off
the curb into the street
losing seven inches then they raise up a
couple of inches
lost a total of five inches of
perspective if you can't see the bus
from up there you're not gonna be able
to see it from down there
so now you have the irony of stepping up
the curb to look for the bus
built into that story and you know
people laugh at the irony also
that's silly why would he do that
superiority we feel superior to that
person
and so that'll get the audience and uh
you know recognition observation and
coincidence oh my god i see that all the
time how come i never thought about it
that way
so those little nuances sometimes
produce
the material but then you say how can i
put it what so what will make it funny
irony will make it funny hypocrisy will
make it funny because
usually irony is uh usually hypocrisy
contains some level of irony
paradox will make it funny um
incongruity
you know what make it funny uh if you
have a reverse shadow an assumption
that would make it funny um you know
it's like you know you're talking about
the person waiting for the bus
it's like you know then they go out in
the street they raise up on their toes
which is weird because they're
in a wheelchair um that could make it
funny um
and then you could so you see what i'm
saying there's like if you know these
if you know the techniques which come
from practicing those one and two liners
even if that's not your thing man
my thing when i'm up on stage is not one
and two liners i'm doing stories
i'm doing experiences i'm talking about
you know things that happened to me and
how i encountered an obstacle on my way
to a goal
i'm not like uh you know two guys walk
into a bar
but it's writing those one and two
liners that get me that proficiency to
be able to take
just write a story then come back
through and go
joke here joke there joke there joke
there okay riff off on that go off in
this direction come back to the story
you know all of that now is possible
because i can see that
in the material because of the you know
there's 13 comedy structures to work
from
plus other you know cliche reformations
and analogies and
that are instant you know built-in tools
to
punch up us a script you know to punch
up a story
you know you need a look at bill burr
his whole act is driven through his
likes
is like it's like his life is like his
like and all he's doing is putting these
two
similar ideas together boom punching it
up hitting some imagery
moving on with his story with a very
strong emotional commitment to
his point of view which is you know it
made him uh
you know the famous bill bereas today
but he uses a lot of big is like to get
there but you got to keep in mind
bill burr the first five to seven years
of his career
he was doing one and two liners because
he had to know how to write a joke
and now when his stories it's easier to
get to that joke because of that
experience of writing jokes
even you know it's like your scales if
you're playing guitar playing piano you
don't know your scales
it's going to be really hard for you to
do studio work
you know so it's learning the
fundamentals
you know as comics we want to get there
so quickly we want to get to the show
and we want to get the you know people
get up there but you get a comic up
there the moment they say what else
i tune out what else what else what else
what else you didn't do your homework
bro
you know that's what else you know you
gotta you gotta
you gotta do your homework i'm old
school that way it's like
if these guys are paying for these seats
i'd better be prepared to bring them a
show
otherwise i'm disrespecting them you
know and you're there to give them a
gift without them or nothing
oh [ __ ] them now we got zoom
you can just see how unfulfilling that
is for some people right it's like
there's nobody watching what do i do i
need that accolade
do you think those are still worth it
the zoom shows absolutely yeah
because they teach you another level
they teach you to relate to this thing
right there
right and it's like you this is that's
unusual
but how does that impact you now if you
get an agent you start doing commercials
and now you have no problem talking to
the camera like i'm talking to you guys
right i'm looking in your eyes
right but it's so weird because in
comedy we don't look in everybody's eyes
at the exact same time so it's a little
different but you can you can actually
use it and
ponder and do that sort of thing you can
use your your framing to go you know
it's like uh you know it's like and i
can't do this and you know it's like i
can't do anything because i'm jewish
i can't you know i can't uh i can't
watch stranger things on the sabbath i
can't do this and it's like
i can't covet my neighbor's wife and
she's hot you know always coming over
what another cup of sugar
so you can do that and use the frame
to create the joke so if you're
imagining what's
what's what they're seeing in the frame
you could utilize that to your advantage
and they force you to be more creative
now so
but you see how that you're seeing it in
a different perspective too
now they could see your eyes now you can
do facials now you can do things with
your eyebrows that maybe you didn't do
before
right you know used to do a true and
false quiz in class you know
my friend and i would send signals he'd
he'd study one night i'd study it the
next night would split the work
in half next day he'd be looking at the
at the question he'd go
all right that was true you'd send the
signals that one's
he has no idea you know so now you have
now you could do that where they
wouldn't be able to see you up on the
stage in the back
from the back of the room so there's
those advantages
also watch john john oliver
watch how he when he first started after
the pandemic
doing the shows sort of remotely and how
it evolved
and he's just like wow he doesn't even
stop for the laugh
it's just it happens by accident
and it's so riveting that's why he won
another emmy
you know because that's something to
to take from if you see so if you join
these
zoom shows see what other people are
doing steal the moves that are working
if the oh that guy gave a look like that
that seemed to really get a lap oh i can
use facial expressions
i can do a deadpan i go you know and she
wants me to come over
get him to use that camera to your uh to
your affected
shift a dynamic level in your act you
know
it's like you know and this is all going
on of course
during the pandemic you know or
during the apocalypse you know that
gives it a conspiratorial
type of thing you know use that camera
as you're leaning in and trying to
whisper to them
so that's a that this this zoom thing
provides other creative opportunities
you know all crisis leads to some sort
of opportunity
i love that did that answer your
question man
are you in class right now you had to
break from class to be here
um yeah actually i'm in my um storage
room
for the school i'm in hiding for my uh
principal
how long have you been doing comedy bow
two years
two years awesome and what made you want
to get uh jerry back on
um actually i took um i think it was pla
late last year i took jerry's um he had
a one day
class session on a saturday and so i
took that and then i watched the um
the master class that you did with him
and i remember him saying
that um even if you took like steve
martin's master class he's
referencing jerry um and yeah
a bunch of my kids said that they said
hey dude what do you think of the steve
martin master class i go he's a living
legend
take it and it's 99 bucks man to hear
from a living legend you've got to get
something some value out of that
and then a bunch of them started calling
me saying he's
he's sending us to when it comes to
writing he's sending us to your website
for your 13 comedy structures what the
[ __ ]
wow
right and we have so many students in
joel's classes and
during the q and a sessions asking the
big questions of like late night comedy
and where do i get started how do i get
certain and i always go back to having
read jerry's book also
jerry's got the answers for a lot of
this stuff so let's try to get him back
on this show that way those q and a's
and actually all the questions i've
asked
are actually questions that other people
have asked um
i know have asked joel in the q and a's
and so i'm just asking their questions
yeah man this that's what i i never
thought i would write for late night tv
i wanted to just be a stand-up you know
i wanted to find a way to work when i
wasn't working as an actor
and that was a performance thing and i
found this little ad that said take a
stand-up class i took the stand-up class
and i found out there were tools so my
thing as a kid i always took apart my
toys to see how they worked and so you
know when the teacher was
like sometimes you just got to be funny
and one teacher i studied with
i i won't mention the name uh because it
would be indiscreet
judy carter but she uh and i'm kidding i
have all respect for all teachers that
are out there and i do that in fun and
in games so if they take offense to that
they shouldn't be in comedy
um but she said well sometimes you have
to coax your audience and sometimes like
when i do a joke i'll do this
and i was like wow uh hello if you do
that you've got to reevaluate your punch
line
right so because you shouldn't have to
go
ta-da you know that's not comedy that's
magic right
so um but what i saw
and so i got some value out of that
every class gave me a little bit of
different value right so
i i my first teacher was greg dean i got
some value out of that but i said hmm
there are some mechanics here
but what really what makes that brain
trigger the laugh what what stimuli is
there there are guys that get up there
and just
you know talk forever and nothing
happens why
what was there and i then i collected
like every video
i could record and i'd go through each
one and say
why did they laugh why did they laugh
where did they laugh then i found melvin
hellitzer's book comedy writing secrets
and he sort of started to label some of
the stuff and i go aha that's what i'm
looking for
and i built off of his labeling and then
i was taking it on the road then i met
gene parrott
and then um bob mills and they
helped tweak some more of what i was
doing and then i
experimented more on the road i was on
the road 43 weeks out of the year for
like 25 years
you know so i was able to get up every
night and try [ __ ]
and test that [ __ ] in a theory and have
notebooks filled with just like
you know constant like what if i did
this whatever now what are they laughing
at
so then i said what would i call that
well so-and-so calls it this so i'm
going to try to
try to keep this a more of a unified
sort of language
so that this terminology can be reused
and people like call back i love that
the people are now they know what a call
back is and it's like act out we know
what that is
uh so three-way build-up or triple we
know what that is
and so now you know people start to
learn incongruity compare and contrast
and and benign retaliation and all this
stuff they can now
sort of create sort of a a theory that's
similar to music theory and just like in
music theory you gotta know the rules
before you can break those rules
so but if people sit there and they sit
down and write
every day for late it's a different
format it's a little more fickle
you're writing for somebody else it's a
host some hosts will say some jokes
other hosts won't say other jokes like
if i submitted a joke to
dave letterman that talked about
[ __ ] i wouldn't get the job
you know um but leno might do it because
it's naughty
you know and it doesn't say butt [ __ ]
but he would say something
that related to that but it's still that
joke and
letterman was just like so against that
um he wouldn't do some of the jokes that
uh
leno did about uh monica lewinsky and
the you know the stain on the blue dress
that wasn't uh letterman's thing so you
got to know your show
too that's why when i do the late night
class the whole
the late night class that i teach live
um by the way it's coming up i think
october 1st
that is we do it every week you have
assignments we have
goals we review the jokes and you get
more tidbits that's why people have
like repeated the class because they get
better and better
some of these cats man they came in and
they were mediocre
stellar jokes stellar jokes stellar joke
one or you know
doesn't what but then they fix it and
now they're getting so good at that
so you can actually see their
improvement as
they progress through this and some of
these guys say
i keep submitting i got a couple of
calls but
never i didn't get the job yet but
that's why i'm going to keep taking the
class because it keeps me accountable
and it's and it's worth the investment
if you will for your career because it
is going to get you to the job i mean
remember i was coaching with these guys
once a week for 18 months
back in 1888 paying them 125 dollars a
class
i charge that for one on ones now and
i got a second job to fund that but
after that investment of what twelve
thousand dollars whatever it was
i made that easily back in the first you
know few months
on my with my job and now that job also
gave me a credential
and a a a status now i could walk into
the improv or the comedy store oh he
writes for the tonight show hey you want
a spot
no waiting in line anymore so it's just
that it's how the business works you're
that little extra piece of legitimacy
maybe you know that says hey this guy
he's it also hey we got a writer for the
tonight show here tonight
that gives their club more legitimacy
so that's why that was so valuable for
me and now
and to get when i started writing
screenplays
oh you wrote for the tonight show for
eight years yeah come on we won't we
have a meeting
when before knocking on that door would
that getting that meeting would have
been tougher
but now i get the meeting because now
that we wrote the film the film got made
now i'm getting meetings all the time
and selling
scripts some of them none of them have
been made yet
but i'm getting there one of my students
just got a film made that kelsey grammer
is in and john cleese
the shooting in uh in the uk starting
this week so that's so exciting
he was like one of my students and now
he's got a film
you know that's amazing that's it's so
exciting to see that man
and then they send you a card with a
bottle maker's mark or something they
say thanks for my career
that's so cool it's just like there's no
money that can replace that you know
well bo do you have any um i went over
time with jerry again i know our last
one turned into a two-hour thing
um bo do you have any closing questions
before we uh
let jerry get back to the golf course
no i'm good yeah i got to go back to the
doctor she gave me this
this medicine that's turning me like red
have you have you noticed that how red i
got yeah i just looked at myself like
what is that's got to be that photo
maybe that's photosensitive the
medicine that i got oh weird look how
red i got that's like i got a i got a
sunburn
from the screen of the computer you look
great buddy
you're you're beautiful jerry and this
was super helpful
um yeah a lot of people are making
comments about how helpful this was and
thanks for doing it and all that jazz
and uh bo
you know i mean thanks for putting us
together man you know reached out to
jerry you you scheduled the day and the
time
because jerry and i tried to do this
several months ago
and it's i mean scheduling and
coordinate like it's
hosting a podcast and interviewing
people there's so many layers to it so
i'm glad that it happened now where
it's a member of the community taking
action and making things happen so beau
thank you i know chris grulon has done
this as well
so um yeah yeah thank you jerry as well
for doing this
no my pleasure man when we did this the
first time i thought it was like
i go when i saw your uh seminar on the
podcast thing i go
this guy really cares he gives a [ __ ]
yeah he really likes this he likes to
help
i know that's me too and it's like i
loved it people say don't just tell me
you're doing this because you love to
help
i go that's how it started i really
wasn't making any money i was just
helping people
you know i'd be on the road and bookers
would put people on the road that were
new and needed
that had promise and needed sort of some
guidance and i would take them out there
and show them
and help them tweak jokes and you know
give them some suggestions to get better
always with positivity always with
positivity
you know you hit them with positivity
and then and then show where the
weakness is
and so because getting up there by
yourself with no fourth wall
not hiding in a character just you it's
super vulnerable
so if you take them down first
you're now working in a deficit rather
than saying
you know what you're spontaneous jokes
aren't there but they're spontaneous
now let's work on let's figure out how
to get there
and like this joke you can do this and
this joke you could do this now it's a
matter of keeping it spontaneous because
that's your craft
your craft is taking the words that are
on the page and making it sound like
they're just off the top of your head
that's craft right so that's what
comedians don't understand
it's like if you write it it's not funny
anymore
you you're not using the part of your
brain we use to talk
writing and talking two totally
different things so once you write it
now you have a record of it you can
you know you could refer to it again and
then you can also tweak it
soon you'll start thinking and writing
the way you
speak and make that easier but now
taking it up there and getting up there
and making it sound like it's right off
the top of your head
that's your craft and that takes
practice so
on that you know and these zoom things
help because this is a different
format how do we still stay
conversational in this talking to a
camera
sort of thing yeah you know it's true
and yeah people are turning in uh from
india they said this was worth staying
up late
for all the way from india that's
awesome um
wow that's awesome yeah and uh yeah
that's one of the core values of hot
breath
is uh it's positivity community and
productivity
so it's like we're willing to work hard
and also support each other in that
all with a positive attitude so and
synergy man
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah
bo could you do you have anything you'd
like to promote before we uh let jerry
land this plane no nothing at the moment
so twitter do you have so you want
people to follow you or anything
oh yeah i mean i have i do um i am on
twitter
no you're great buddy i like i just got
a message too at the same time when you
ask that um
i'm on twitter um instagram and facebook
at
b johnson comedy beautiful and jerry
yeah please let people know because i've
i use you as like a
like a resource like if someone asked me
a question i'm like i could tell you my
experience
this guy not only has more experience he
has several different resources
free and paid that you can use so i
constantly refer people to you
so please let them know where um these a
la carte things you're doing are great
i know a lot of hot breath hit me up on
my twitter
at joke doctor right so that's and if
you're not on twitter
uh you can go to uh visit me on facebook
uh and it's also uh jokedover at you
know it's
facebook.com forward slash stand-up
comedy clinic
uh hence the joke doctor thing and that
was a name that was given to me by
you know veterans at the friars club
when i would we would have these little
writer sessions and i would tweak their
jokes and fix their jokes
they're like you're like you fix jokes
you make them well you're like the joke
doctor
and that's stuck you know and i was like
oh that's such a neat little thing
because
i'm the new guy and these guys been
around for a long time but they didn't
they just sort of you know they wrote
with hope all their lives
and then if a joke was funny they kept
it if it wasn't they dropped it
but there were jokes that they didn't
think they were going to drop i'd go
you're just missing a connector
and then we'd put it in the joke worked
and they're like how did you do that you
know
it's just a lot of practice i think is
how that comes about and really studying
really getting there studying the
mechanics rather than just believing
either got it or you don't
you know yeah i think that's the big
overall takeaway today is
well learn the rules before you break
them but like yeah learn the mechanics
work hard at those mechanics to learn
them and make them a reflex
and then like make them your own but it
all comes down to work
being willing to put in the work period
so thank you you've helped so many
different what they're saying from
germany here
all across the world um thank you so
much jerry uh hop read the verse
all of the links that he said that jerry
said and that beau said will be in the
show notes if you want to get involved
in future q a's like this
you've got to be involved in our
facebook group you're watching on
youtube you're listening to the podcast
join the facebook group get involved in
the write 10 club
and um we'll be back with another q a
soon thank you so much
jerry and uh bo thanks for putting this
together buddy
thank you thanks for putting that
together and um um
uh your principal just called me said do
you know where bo is
she just actually she just called me so
all right well we took kleinder oh well
yeah you go answer that that's your job
for now buddy until we make comedy your
job
and um that's right have a good day guys
thank you so much
if you're serious about becoming a
comedian join our facebook group linked
in the description below to start
getting tips like these
every single day and watch this playlist
of our top writing tips to improve your
writing
[Music]
today